bendy Irwin reveals she's been fighting
a secret Health Battle it's just as
important to have that support team
around you those people who are
constantly giving you that love and
light because you are going to have
challenging days bendy posted this photo
of herself in a hospital bed to
Instagram and in the caption she shares
She's suffering from endometriosis a
disorder that causes tissue to grow
outside the uterus the star says she's
been dealing with insurmountable fatigue
pain and nausea for the last decade
writing quote trying to remain a
positive person and hide the pain has
been a very long road there's a lot of
things that happen along the way that
affect you and change you and just that
life experience it filled you to be the
person that you are bendy adds that
after many tests and doctor's visits
including a doctor who she claims
dismissed her experience she decided to
undergo surgery she writes quote going
in for surgery was scary but I knew I
couldn't live live like I was every part
of my life was getting torn apart
because of the pain to cut a long story
short they found 37 lesions some very
deep and difficult to remove and a
chocolate cyst just to be able to share
some of my story and to kind of reach
out to people in a new way to be able to
just Inspire others to say this is what
I've learned and just to know that
you're not alone on your journey there
are other people who have experienced
similar things the TV personality who
was now on the road to recovery shares
this reminder with fans quote things may
look fine on the outside looking in
through someone else's life however that
is not always the case she adds quote
please be gentle and pause before asking
me or any woman one will be having more
children after all that my body has gone
through I feel tremendously grateful
that we have our gorgeous daughter she
feels like our family's miracle she is
just the light of Our Lives bendy and
her husband Chandler welcomed their
first child Greatest Warrior Erwin
Powell in 2021 last year bendy and her
mom Terry opened up to ET about how
little Grace is a light in their lives
it's so nice for us because we live and
work right here at Australia Zoo which
is our beautiful Wildlife Sanctuary so
Grace is just always with me no matter
what whether we're at the Australia Zoo
Wildlife hospital or in the middle of a
management meeting she is always with me
and I I feel incredibly lucky that we
get to do that I feel so lucky that she
can be part of every day of my life and
and watching her soak in the world
around her has been truly magical she's
got that determination that Steve had
and that connection with Wildlife
because it is weird to see animals just
gravitate to her so she'll go out in the
morning in the stroller and all the
kangaroos just gather around her like
they're having a meeting oh my God the
koalas I don't need to interrupt but
through koalas literally climb out of
their trees
foreign